[Music]
it's a piece of advice that has nevertheless
demonstrated a unity that doesn't have a façade
but is solid,
just like the last five
years we've been able to act
together,
we often say, and that's not  not always
have to be whole sections where
the European Union has not been able to
meet expectations, but of the 348
regulations directives that the commission
proposed, 90% of them were
unanimously approved
tweak s  however, don't stop there mental
actions of the idf martin shibbye youtube
higgins kachine handnews priority either
2.4 ghz with steve hansen understood from
the idef category ladies street day want
to take for political responsibility
our single heaven his challenger beats
ford european union  01/10 drinkable in
sibiu in mind that really it continues
I would say that that of rim supports
european construction
amado pato political
declaration declaration of the cie bio respect ramona
ou ne landmark important
historia the european union
[Music  e]